listen cold how much how much alcohol
have you had tonight one drink okay one
drink I did I'd have one drink uh and I
can have one two
four it's cold it's cold out here I'm
sorry but I did have one drink tonight I
did I did um one miss you can stop the
test you can stop sorry you can stop
it's just cold outside tonight it
doesn't matter how many Mississippi I've
had I've had one drink tonight and it
doesn't matter if I five 10 Mississippi
it's a form count stop stop stop stop
stop stop sorry it's a form accounting 1
1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 4 1,000 I get it
you understand that yeah yeah yeah look
it's just cold 1 1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 4
and so forth you understand that can you
try counting in that manner okay all
right 1 1,00 2 I'm sorry I have the
heels on I want to like hold on to
something for a second I have heels on
I'm sorry you understand that yes ma'am
yes sir sorry that's all right all right
go ahead count out loud 1
6 7 8 O
9 10 eight on the pivot I'm sorry sorry
and 10
also turn around 10 n oh sorry sorry
sorry
10 10 and I'm sorry I start over again
at one yes okay
one
you sorry
sir all right so what happened ma'am
were you um so the light was red and
then it turned green for us to go so it
was going and unfortunately it didn't go
so yeah you got to use your use your
words what happened you you ran into it
what happened so the green the light was
green I'm ready to go yes and she wasn't
going so unfortunately I
went unfortunately I was going and she
wasn't going when the light was green
did you hit the bra stop no I didn't I
figured it was green so we were going
you have unfortunately I could get stop
in time so I thought the light was green
were going so
unfortunately when the light was green
yeah okay do you have your license
frustration Insurance on
you he knows there's a ticket on your
car
H like stair key
somewhere
if you want to hang in your car I know
it's cold out here
I'll sorry what information did you need
I need your license your registration
and your
insurance do you have any of those
documents in your car I I have all of
the above they're all active but maybe
not in the car that they are um active
but they where are you coming from
tonight my short I'm coming from work
and I'm going home where do you work at
I work in um Asberry Park New Jersey and
I work in and I prob rather live in news
Red Bank New
Jersey have you to drink in asbery no
I'm sorry um I live in Asbury I work in
Asbury Park I'm sorry I'm still like new
with the area I'm um I went from like
Bergenfield Bergenfield and then from
Bergenfield to asber park then I hope
you understand what you're telling me
nothing nothing's making sense I'm sorry
what can I tell you that have you had
anything have you had anything to drink
no I have not you've had no drinks
tonight no I have not okay would you be
okay if I put you through a series of
tests just to make sure you're okay
that's fine all right I'm just going to
wait for another unit to get here all
right that's fine what information do
you need I need your license your
registration and your insurance all
right license you got already license
you got already any of
that 3
County saying that if you ring the bell
she should answerer the door um she's
usually a pretty light sleeper he's
do you have insurance oh are you yes I
do ma'am yeah where is it um I just need
to see it okay sorry um I'm sorry I have
two cell phones I'm trying to just um
yep I need that that's your registration
what that this is registration that's
reg y you need insurance yes so where
are you coming from tonight hold on one
second I'm just coming from from work
com and trying to get a ride home you're
trying to get a ride home not trying get
a ride home I'm trying to get to home
home okay are you sure you haven't had
anything to drink tonight no I have not
okay well I smell the odor of alcoholic
ravage coming off your breath from
people at my work I I work with a lot of
clients with substance Abus and
unfortunately that's what I work with I
hope you understand the way you're
slurring your words and your story is
not making sense right now I do
apologize I work with a lot of cents
with clients with substance Abus okay
and unfortunately that's what I work
with
uh-huh um thank you 63 you available I'm
sorry I can
um can you look up your insurance me
please
okay okay I'll get you out of here in a
couple minutes okay yeah no problem
thank
you your car you're drivable right
that's that's the only damage you have
damage I should be fine okay I got to
take couple pictures of that
you get just hang in your car
please AV to break from a
reg sorry should I my turn car on or
should I turn off just leave it just sit
in your car just stay there I'll be with
you in just a minute leave it on and
turn it off y stay there leave on yeah
thank you
okay
um I got to do feel soety with her
she's um wait where where
we
BMW rear ended the Chevy the white Chevy
at this like
smoker which
one they're both
F no she's sitting in her car okay yeah
so you want to run her through side
yeah the girl in the white I just got to
give her herh chees to do I know it's
terrible
[Music]
so what do you do it's a busy ass
intersection I thought I was going to
whip around and do it right here with
all these
cars unless you stay where you're at and
can you back up yeah all right why you
back up can I cut the other girl loose
or no yeah once I give her her stuff
yeah okay
Bo got
canak for
the all right um you're all good uh this
is a crash card it's going to have all
the information for the police report
the insurance information and all that
um here's the case number here it's TF
like Falls has to get Toad I'm staying
out here with her okay um if you have
any questions feel free to reach out
just give it like five to seven business
days to process and they can access the
report and then so oh so I just go to
that website all right time for with the
other party stand by one minute okay I
see it okay okay any questions feel free
to give us a call all right sounds good
all right all
right stand by real quick ma'am can I
just grab your phone number just to add
it to
the okay thank you and the light
was thank
you
no CU she's coming from work but I smell
it on
her you want like the take Downs on
no
M yeah I KCK the other girl
loose I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry is
it Andre Andre and and okay can you hop
out real quick for me
yeah right let's go over here SC toic
real quick
so you haven't had anything to drink
tonight right no where are you coming
from I'm coming from work okay where you
going home home okay and you had no
alcoholic beverages no I did not I smell
the alcohol coming off your breath the
odor of alcohol there was a girl having
drinks while I was having out of work
that was that of work okay can I run you
through a series of tests just to make
sure you're okay anything you feel
comfortable with okay
the line or
what all right so stay there for a
second stay there stay
there watch me okay you don't have to
stand like that stay comfortable you can
watch
me the first test is called a walk and
turn okay don't do it yet first test is
called a walk and turn you're going to
take nine Heel To Toe steps forward arms
at your sides looking down one 2 3 4 4 5
6 7 8 9 then you're going to turn on
your outside foot all the way around and
do the same thing back nine Heel To Toe
steps one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 all about
counting out
loud you understand those rules yes
ma'am okay are you comfortable doing it
in those shoes yes ma'am I'm going to
put you in the starting position I want
face this way can stand right here
please sorry that's all right I'm going
to have you face this way face face this
there you go and you're going to put
your right foot in front of your left
sorry I'm in heels do you you can take
them off do you want to take them off
okay um it would be more comfortable if
I would but if I do have them on still
feel a little bit more comfortable I
would like to try to do with the on just
so that you don't have Sho in the car do
you I don't I don't I don't okay so
you're going to keep your hands arms at
your sides
sorry so you understand the directions
that the officer gave you 1 2 3 4 5 6
7even 8 n okay so you're going sorry
sorry sorry it's just the heels so with
that right foot stting in front okay
you're going to take your first step is
going to be your left foot you're going
to take nine step one sorry you're going
to take those nine steps forward stop
pivot and turn back and take nine steps
back you understand that yes ma'am yes
sir sorry that's all right all right go
ahead count out loud one
two
6 7 8 O
9 10 eight on the pivot I'm sorry sorry
and 10
also you turn around 10 oh sorry sorry
sorry
10 10 and I'm sorry I start over again
at one yes okay
one
10 11 you to stop 12 sorry sir so I I
I'm not sure if you understand the
direction I'm sorry if you can please
explain them to me okay I'm going to
show I'm going to show them to you again
okay please I'm sorry watch watch my
feet you see my feet yes sir okay look
see I have I have my right foot in front
of my left and the heel to tell
Manor sorry sorry sorry sorry it's cold
I'm sorry look at my hands I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm just
cold listen look at I'm sorry okay yes
yes yes yes yes foot my foot in front of
my f yes I'm sorry officer yes yes yes
yes I'm sorry I'm trying to hold on you
for for um for warmth okay here's what's
going to happen sorry you what has to
happen is you got to complete these
tests I understand if you don't complete
the tests and and we think that you're
impaired you're going to be arrested
for understand okay so in a with your
right foot in front of your left okay do
not start in a heal to show in a heel to
heel to toe fashion I need you to take
nine steps forward and N St back watch
my feet one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 you're going
to Pivot you're going to turn back one
two three four five 6 S 8 n did you see
that I appreciate it sir thank you you
think that you can do that yes sir okay
let's try that
again
[Applause]
for the next test what I want you to do
is is I'm I'm going to have you step a
little bit more over here stand over
here please all right St right there I'm
sorry I have to use the restroom that's
what it is I'm sorry last test okay this
is what I want you to do use the rest I
want you to put your hands out of your
pockets on the side okay what I need you
who's that it's the other party can't um
what I need you to do I'm not talking to
someone the party I'm sorry no not
listen you're going to step forward step
forward before you fall over the the
curse okay what I want you to do is
you're going to keep your hands down by
your side okay what I want you to do is
I want to raise your foot either your
left or your right foot 6 in off the
ground with your toe pointed up in this
manner feet are
together put is off the ground for 6 in
put your toe up you're going to stare at
your toe and you're going to
count and so
forth you understand that yes sir
okay you can begin test minut sorry
sorry sorry I'm close one Mississippi
two
Mississippi I'm
cold hold on hold on hold on hold on one
miss two miss miss four
Miss I know it's cheating if I hold on
to one of you right yeah how listen it's
cold how much how much alcohol have you
one drink one drink I did I'd have one
drink uh and I can have one two
four it's cold it's cold out here I'm
sorry but I did have one drink tonight I
did I did um one
miss oh sorry outs it's just cold
outside tonight it doesn't matter how
many Mississippi I've had I've had one
drink tonight and it doesn't matter if I
have five or 10
Mississippi literally is it cold I'm
sorry counted 1 1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 4
1,000 I get it you understand that yeah
yeah yeah look this is cold 1 1,00 2
1,000 3 1,000 4 and so so forth you
understand that you start counting in
that manner okay right 1 1,00 two I'm
sorry I have heels on I want to like
hold on to something for a second I have
heels on I'm sorry what is the um what
is up what is up about H this behind my
got it this is even easier I'm
sorry I can
count I'm sorry I can count a lot more
on this they
give no I'm very
sorry all right
ready
no do you understand what you're being
placed under arrest for no I do not it
is very cold outside so I cannot the
influence I understand now but it is
very cold outside that I can't even I
before you my urine won't even come out
because of whatever however the
temperature it is outside of out it is
okay I just have to search you okay do
you have anything on you no absolutely
not okay where's your phone or my phone
and everything is in the vehicle in the
car okay yeah okay you just face this
way
please get a property yeah what what do
you need your phone in the vehicle
everything is in the vehicle my pH my
car keys are in the vehicle everything
is in the vehicle all right I got the
keys here
okay I want to get your I you have to
use the rest sorry TI I'm going to get
your cell phone and I'm going to cell
phone and insurance and vehic and
insurance is I got the insurance it's on
her phone the phone yes the phone it's
everything is on the vehicle I'm
sorry so
cold sorry I don't
have not a criminal I got you not a
criminal no I
understand you're just doing your
job help wait push
me push me thank you put your fo down
there and push push me thank you you in
all right thank you thank you I
understand everybody's just doing their
job I also just do my job I work at an
daycare center and trust me when I have
to send the people to the police I'm
just doing my job I got you sorry I
don't mean to be rude I'm trying to know
I understand like to also send them to
the